مسلسل من حلقات محدوده ام بمواسم متعدده
وحبكه دراميه متقلبه غموض يزيد ولا ينقص
لما جرى في روسيا السبت الماضي اهوه تمرد
كما يسميه الكرملين اما مسرحيه كما يصفها
خصوم بوتين ام صراع اجنحه داخل البيت
الروسي ام فوضى نجحت موسكو في احتوائها
قبل فوات الاوان ام ماذا بالضبط من سحاب
قواته من مخطط الزحف الى موسكو الذي لم
يعمر سوى ساعات لم تنتهي القصه ولم تقلب
صفحه الخصومه قائد مجموعه في ضيافه الرئيس
البيلاروسي لوكاشينكو منذ صباح الثلاثاء
الرئيس الذي تولى الوساطه تتحدث ربما اكثر
من اللازم عن تفاصيل الاتصالات التي
اجراها مع بوتين وبريكوجين قال لوكاشينكو
ان بوتين كان يريد تصفيه الطباخه السابق
ولكنه دع الى عدم القيام بذلك ولكن ماذا
ينتظر بريكوجين ورفاقه بعد الان هل
الاقامه في بيلاروسيا ستكون طويله ام
قصيره كان الرئيس بوتين وضمن اتفاقه مع
نظيره البيلاروسي لاحمد دينار الفتنه عطل
قرار الملاحق القانونيه وخير مقاتلي
المجموعه العسكريه بين العوده الى منازلهم
او الانخراط في الجيش النظامي او التوجه
الى الجاره بلاروسيا بالرغم من المشهد
القاتم والعلاقه المتشابكه بين الكرملين
وفاكنر موسكو غير مستعده لتسليم
ولا غيره لاي دوله اخرى من اجل محاكمته
[موسيقى]
في الجانب القانوني المتعلق بالتسليم
استطيع القول ان اي مواطن روسي لا يخضع
للتسليم لاي دوله اخرى وله الحق في اي
يعول على مساعده روسيا لحمايته من
المحاولات غير القانونيه
لتحميله المسؤوليه الجنائيه في الخارج
اشرت الخارجيه الروسيه ايضا الى ان
الزعماء الافارقه هم اصحاب قرار مواصله
العمل من عدمه مع مجموعه فاغنر قبل يومين
من هذا الكلام كان وزير الخارجيه
اكد استمرار عمل المجموعه في افريقيا
الوسطى ومالي صخر الكريم من محتوى تقرير
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز وجاء في التقرير
استنادا الى مصدر في المخابرات الامريكيه
ان الجنرال
نائبه قائد العمليات العسكريه في اوكرانيا
كان على علم بالتمرد قبل وقوعه علقت قائلا
انه ستكون هناك الكثير من التكهنات
والشائعات وما الى ذلك بشان هذه الاحداث
مضيفا ان ما ورد في التقرير مجرد نموذج
بالنسبه في السبت ماده قابله للاستغلال
الى ابعد الحدود وان حاول الرئيس جو بايدن
التاكيد اعتبار مجره شان داخليا لا يخفي
شمتته من عدوه اللدود في موسكو
من الواضح ان بوتين يخسر الحرب في
اوكرانيا ويخسر حرب الداخل واصبح منبوذا
نوعا ما في جميع انحاء العالم
بعد بيلاروسيا اين ستذهب فاجنر ورئيسها هل
ستحل لتعود بعلامه تجاريه جديده ورئيس
اكثر ولاء للمؤسسه العسكريه الروسيه واقل
تهورا هل ستبقى كما هي ولكن تحت اي بند
ستكون علاقتها مع الكريم بعد الان